this is a
a lightning slot but we've found the
time to fill so it's really a as a
velvet practical data science project
I'm a past history in consulting and
data analysis and customer insight and
more recently going more less alone
there's a independent consultant and got
a couple other guys subcontracting with
me and though that's the applied a I
think and we're tackling a bunch of
different projects in different
companies and they are sometimes a lot
sometimes more this was quite a small
one this was where we were talking to a
nangi supplier and they had collected
over the course of about 10 or so years
a hundred thousand or so accounts these
are energy supply accounts so it's
either a gas installation or an
electricity installation in a promises a
shop or a business a company something
and that was fine but they put it in in
a piecemeal and a bit by bit and not
really paid any attention to any kind of
grouping so it became the situation that
they had out of these hundred thousand
accounts a bunch of companies that
actually only each account so franchises
and so on and they want to start
targeting males and targeting marketing
and so on to a company at the company
level so if you've got ten installations
they just want to some that aggregate it
and give giving one marketing message
once which is a little bit
time-consuming to then look through
manually and decide that these companies
accounts or belong to one company so
this is a good opportunity to do some
natural language processing and using
just that data try to pre aggregate and
make suggestions of accounts which
appeared sufficiently similar so lots of
fairly rudimentary things that we went
through so just thought I'd
draft up a quick fast food based example
of some of the data and some of the
things that we were looking at so for
instance Bob's pizza is in here a couple
of times oh i should add this is what
we're trying to find this this orange
bit this isn't this wasn't present in
the data only the gray stuff so Bob's
pizza might be in there twice you can
order it alphabetically by account name
and all right it more or less turns up
the information that we had was things
like account name contact name premises
and a billing address and in this case
right Bob's pizza a couple of different
sites this is in Ireland by the way
asain billing address so you could
probably order it by account name and
get it figured out but what about Mike's
kebabs which is actually owned by Mike
but it's also in dublin and the billing
address is the same what about mark's
kebabs which comes very next down and
it's very close in dublin but the
billing address is different and it's no
different guy what about Fred's falafel
where we've got two different accounts
in slightly different places possibly
maybe this is a duplication maybe it's
not it's very hard to tell so what we
were trying to do what they wanted to be
able to do is put human eyes on this but
with a hundred thousand or so accounts
this is a big load of data to chew
through and so what we wanted to do is
give them a little head start so this
was a very short project only about a
week or so to do some initial processing
so we can start doing some clustering
and then feed the results of that
clustering to humanize a bunch of
interns to actually do that human
interpretation before putting on too
the actual client themselves so we used
them some fun stuff in Psych it's learn
and an l TK which guys have already
mentioned a little bit today and I won't
pretend to know more than I do there's
nary and Bart mentioned some tools which
are probably the same ones were released
very similar to the same tool kits so we
did some did some pausing some cleaning
fairly proprietary just trying to
spelling correct sometimes trying to
limit eyes sometimes trying to strip out
a needless punctuation the kind of usual
stuff lower casing trying to preserve
though crucial motivation like in
addresses maybe someones at 59 / 61
upper street and you need to preserve
that / because it's actually part of the
address and also with the starting parts
of addresses actually if I go back to
this one we're trying to preserve you
know three upper street is a single
address it needs to be preserved so
we're doing some some things to to keep
those tokens together through the next
bit so once we tokenized it uses of
tf-idf bowties it's fantastic really
really simple and event ended up with a
day the sparse matrix that was about a
hundred thousand rows about 20,000
features just because and this is all
running on a laptop macbook air actually
this isn't mine but little that's all
fine well and good but we don't have any
predictions yet once the run clustering
so transform those into vectors and
ended up through singular value
decomposition ended up with about a
hundred dimensional matrix because then
start doing some clustering upon so we
still have this problem in that we've
got
we've got data points we got accounts
which are similar somehow and we can
group them somehow but they're not
necessarily true companies so the
reversed important part of this is
actually the step to this human
validation verification for a start what
I wanted to do was subdivide this big
set into manageable chunks that people
could then look at so the first step to
try to do some k-means actually use mini
batch because it was ridiculously fast
and I was able to do some grid searching
parameter tuning with that because it
was running in seconds flat on my laptop
and that got us some some splits which
I've marked with the shapes of these
things of course now with the k-means
it's a reasonably arbitrary count of
clusters that you're going to make and
are measuring the Bayesian information
criterion it dropped down to around
about 20 or 30 yards where we were
getting smallish sizes of clusters there
are about four to five thousand members
roughly in each in each cluster and that
felt like a reasonable amount to have in
what would be a CSV file an excel file
actually for for human grouping so once
we got down to about that that size
we're about 25 k-means clusters I
thought within that we should really try
to make life even easier so now we've
got got these vectors in here so thought
I'd try some affinity propagation which
again on smaller cluster sizes worked
reasonably well to gather groups of
around about 20 or so similar accounts
that were similar again now we're not
we're not to the stage of having you
know Mike's what I call in Mad Mike or
somebody not who haven't identified the
actual companies at this stage because
it really required quite a lot of human
interpretation and knowledge of towns
and areas to interpret these addresses
but it at least lets you order the data
set again and have another look at it
and really try to use everything that we
can on an automated fashion to make the
life of these guys tagging everything
much easier and as it was when we got
down to the end after a couple of
iterations of this grouping tagging
grouping tagging we're actually able to
shortcut the process a little bit and
start using some supervisors techniques
so not purely unsupervised but more
supervised techniques to actually
propagate the company identifies through
the set and change sometimes some of the
some of the settings so for instance
this guy you know may have been tagged
as I think this is blue guy after human
verification actually that's not true
that changes this little local area and
any propagation in there changes the
ones that I haven't shown or it could be
that you know the yellow triangle here
was actually part of the company but
misidentified and again this is a very
pragmatic pragmatic process of trying to
make a best guess and then getting
someone to to clarify it but it actually
worked this is the nice thing it it was
only a brief project doesn't mention we
managed to get icy accuracy measures of
her near prone to lies but what I mean
by this is when we finally went to the
the company that we were doing this for
they themselves as industry experts
spent a day or two going through the
lists to verify what we've done and the
corrections they made were such that we
had gotten in ninety-three percent of
them actually right I'm happy with them
we got I should mention actually her so
forty odd percent of the hands turned
out to belong to a company so there's a
lot of just sparse individual accounts
in that but but of those that we did
find roughly 3 3.5 for accounts /
company which is interesting as well
going back to thinking about the
clustering techniques that we could have
used because something like spectral
clustering I am NOT an expert at all but
there were so many different company
accounts that we were trying to get it
was in the ordinary of thousands that we
were trying to get out of there I'm not
sure that kind of clustering would even
work so well so it's very very bitty and
just a nice thing which was the tool
kits are great and really really
straightforward to piece together and to
try this this pipeline so really enjoyed
you using these these toolkits again and
learned a bit more through it and my
final point from it is is simply that if
you can get human eyes on him on the
data to validate and verify what you
found then it becomes even stronger so
that's that's really that thanks